i guess it's not really a rant this is
belichick just
being belichick this is yeah but it's i
mean it's peak belichick
october 5th 2014 monday night football
the kansas city chiefs just absolutely
blast oh new england and tom brady
got taken out of the game it was just
useless to have him still in the game
that was when we
first cup of garoppolo i think we got oh
that's a good fight first cup of
garoppolo
and then uh let's hear the back and
forth uh
between um bill belichick and a very
intrepid reporter for i believe nfl
network at the time go for it
difficult to react to the university of
monday night to get back on track so
quickly because
from a condition standpoint this team
this organization hasn't had these sort
of issues in the past
well we're on to cincinnati
bill do you think you mentioned tom's
age at the draft
it's nothing about the past nothing
about the future right now we're
preparing for cincinnati
okay do you feel like the talent you
have here is good
we're getting ready for cincinnati
well i mean i'm just asked do you think
you've done enough to help to operate
we're getting ready for cincinnati
that's what we're doing
so as you get ready for cincinnati does
tom brady have the talent and protection
around him to be honest
we're going to game plan and do the best
we can to be ready to go sunday night
same as we always do nothing's changed
without the sheer determination of
albert breer to ask multiple follow-up
questions
we would have only had one to moving on
to cincinnati and then we wouldn't have
been done that's it
albert breer from sports illustrated
joining me here on the right charging
show how are you albert
i wish you could see a smile on my face
god wow that's unbelievable i hadn't
heard that in a while so it's good to
hear that again
albert uh i think i counted four
follow-ups
yeah yeah yeah i you know it was
interesting because
that was sort of i i just sort of at
that point taking the approach and there
was a point when i
you know i had a great relationship with
belichick um you know for a lot of years
early in my career and
you know there were a couple things you
know when i was at the boston globe
where where it went off the rails i sort
of made the decision like i
i'm not going to be you know able to ask
these questions in private anymore
you know i got to go out and ask them in
public now um you know and so
you know it was sort of one of those
where there were a few confrontations
between me and bill
and that was the one that actually i
guess got everybody's attention but
that was the story line in boston that
week you know was
um brady's getting older belichick
actually if you if you want to go back
and look at this press conference
volunteered
that part of the reason they drafted
jimmy garoppolo uh
that spring was because of brady's age
and contract situation
and they hadn't played very well i mean
it wasn't just the kansas city game if
you go back and look at it and i got the
schedule up here
they lost to the miami dolphins in the
opener they blew out the vikings in week
two but that was coming
right off of the adrian peterson thing
so the vikings were really on the ropes
and then they struggled against the bad
raiders team who we three before getting
blown out by kansas city and so
you know that team wound up winning the
super bowl but after a month
it was i mean it was it was the question
everyone in boston was asking was
i mean are they acting with enough
urgency in putting this team together
is there a good enough team there uh to
to
to get brady another championship it's
been 10 years since he'd won
one and then of course just my luck um
the patriots i don't believe lost again
until after thanksgiving
and then while they're playing the super
bowl so uh so yeah definitely took on a
different context for long term
well if i'm not mistaken chris brockman
i'm putting two and two together i
believe
this show was one day old we came on the
air on the 4th of october of 2014.
and then we saw that that night and this
is all we talked about on our first full
day talking about in a monday night
football game
that is 100 i think you're just putting
it all together right now
if i'm not mistaken didn't i mean they
told brady for like 10 minutes long they
did i mean
you know why albert albert
i remember this like it was yesterday
because i think i had edelman
in a fantasy league and all i needed was
him to just get 10 more yards
and i would be able to win my game and
garoppolo couldn't do anything and it
was just a total disaster i mean it was
an absolute total
complete meltdown by new england that we
we had not seen in in
forever so these were all questions uh
what was it like though did you realize
you were in the middle of what would be
no doubt something discussed over and
over again when when he did the whole
honda cincinnati i knew it would be
discussed locally because of the
confrontation
a few of these with him right uh and
look i've got all the respect in the
world for for him
i'm doing my job he's doing it you know
and i think right
that's that's part of it you know but i
i you know there were certain times when
i felt like certain questions had to be
asked this is one of them and i
and i um you know so i do like locally
when
he answers the question that way that
this was going to
um that this was going to get like a
sports radio reaction you know in boston
so i knew that
um i don't know if i really had an idea
of the scope of
what that those three words would mean
and i got to give credit here too it
wasn't just me
michelle steele from espn sure was there
too
and it was i i could i vividly remember
this
it was me asking one michelle asking
another
me asking one michelle asking another so
it was sort of back and forth with the
two of us
and um you know as i become pretty
familiar with this part of it too
there was there's always like after i
would be done with one of those lines of
questioning
sort of this awkward five seconds of
silence afterwards like who's going to
ask the next question
so i do remember that part of it too
well
uh if i'm also not mistaken albert uh
you were the one uh holding the
microphone when steve smith told akeeb
to leave to ice up son which is not
really a rant but it's definitely
something
albert correct yeah yeah i i don't know
it won't be number one or number two for
my time at nfl network i have other ones
too
i i'll give you guys another funny one
in a second but that one
i'm sure you've had this this experience
before
do you know like when there's that
moment when it's just like i just got to
put the mic in front of this guy and get
the hell out of the way
sure that's one of them yeah
for me definitely but here's here's
another good one for you
okay so you guys know um you guys of
course know
uh the bart scott rant with sao paulo
right
yeah you can't wait oh okay they can't
wait right rant right
so i was brand new at nfl network at
that point and
you know part of my job at the time big
part of my job at the time is before the
lockout
was um was doing the entrepreneur
interviews after games
and so i covered the jets patriots that
that playoff game
and like literally like the and the jets
of course beating the patriots in a
playoff game i mean it was
like for that team like i mean like i
felt like they'd won the super bowl
and so i was down in the field and i go
out to midfield
and they tell me okay we're gonna get
you braylon edwards braylen edwards
literally did a backflip into my shot
right and then pointed at the cat camera
and just started
yelling at the patriots into the camera
i i'm telling you rich i was so excited
i was like oh my god
i've got gold and of course bart scott
is like 10 feet away
giving sal pal the line of the year
totally upstaged me it was a
heartbreaker
i can't wait i love it albert thanks for
the recollections you take care of
yourself
awesome thanks guys appreciate it yeah
that's all right sports illustrated
right in the mqb hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here